we are joined Now by Republican senator
John thune of the great state of South
Dakota who is also the Senate minority
whip and Senator we mentioned that
private moment I want to get into some
of the the topics of this address but
also the tone because there were public
moments of disagreement we're not used
to seeing at a State of the Union uh the
president was called a liar a couple
times there were some outbursts about
whether he was the blame for the
fentanyl crisis there were definite
Rocky Horror Picture Show Vibes at
various moments here and before we get
into the content I'm curious what you
think the American people should take
away from what they saw last night
well I think Tony what you know they saw
obviously was a president people could
characterize it as a soft launch for his
uh re-election campaign there was a lot
of red meat that he threw out there and
uh the reaction in the chamber was
probably pretty predictable Democrats
were very uh boisterous in their support
and Republicans of course uh not so much
and I think that uh you know again the
the tone of State of the Union speeches
at least in my you know the modern
modern era in which we live politically
there is more I would say activity in
the chamber probably than there used to
be but you know I think that's probably
characterizes a little bit of the change
in our politics I mean people are a lot
more uh you know they get out there a
lot more outspoken and I think the State
of the Union speeches are perhaps a good
example of that
Senator David begno here good morning to
you there were some moments of
bipartisanship right the president
mentioned more police resources and he
recognized the family of Tyree Nichols
and there were a lot of Republicans who
clapped and stood for that are
Republicans ready to work with Democrats
on police reform
we are and I very much hope we that we
can get something done there you know
there was there were attempts made in
the past several attempts made in the
past as recently as 2020 which
eventually sort of fell apart but uh
we've got a great leader on that issue
Senator Tim Scott from South Carolina
has done a lot of good work on police
reform and he really tried to push that
issue forward and in the end it was the
Democrats who walked away from the table
so yes there is there are I think about
70 to 80 percent of the issues around
police reform are things that both sides
agree on so what we ought to try and do
is find that common ground and see if we
can actually execute on on getting some
reforms across the Finish Line I think
the opportunity is there and I hope
there will be the the will on both sides
to to put it together
you know Senator on this question of the
debt ceiling there was a a moment and
this was one of those call and response
moments uh where the president uh
criticized some Republicans for wanting
to make cuts to Social Security some
changes there uh he's referring to a
proposal from Senator Rick Scott someone
who I've actually talked to on this
subject uh but but just to you know be
abundantly clear for the American people
where does your party stand on cuts to
Social Security and Medicare Tony I
think what you heard last night is you
know both sides agreeing that there
aren't going to be cuts to Social
Security or Medicare I do think however
and the debt limit is a good place to do
this is to is to actually realize we got
a 31 trillion dollar debt it's not going
away we spend more than we take in every
year and you can't solve all that just
by raising taxes which is you know a lot
of what the president proposed last
night you actually have to figure out
how do we strengthen these programs and
and that doesn't mean you have to cut
things but there are a lot of younger
Americans today who understand that if
something isn't done they're not Social
Security is going to be around for them
I mean if you you're talking about huge
cuts in this program not too far down
the road when it goes bankrupt if we
don't do some things to make it stronger
and make it viable not just for current
Generations but also for future
generations of Americans and there are
things that are are out there there's a
proposal out there right now which is
bipartisan Bill Cassidy he's got half a
dozen Republicans half a dozen Democrats
on Social Security reform and it does it
in a way that strengthens the program
avoids those steep cuts that would occur
in the future and and I think it's you
know that's the kind of thing we ought
to be talking about because both sides
have to agree we can't sustain this you
can't have 31 trillion dollars of debt
and climbing every year and I think the
president if he wants to this could be a
real Legacy issue he could come to the
table and it's going to take
presidential leadership to do something
big and consequential like this and I
think Republicans would meet him there
yeah we'll see what happens
strengthening the country for the future
is what it is all about a gentleman of
the Senate Senator John thune thank you
very much thanks Tony